il est évident que le texte maintenant
est problématique c'est à dire qu' il ya
des passages ouvertement raciste
[Musique]
le
autant en emporte le vent fait partie
sans conteste des classiques américains
bonjour je m'appelle oliver gallmeister
et je suis éditeur
c'est un livre qui a été un monument de
la littérature américaine du 20e siècle
qu'il a été écrit pendant dix ans entre
1926 1936 il s'est vendu dit-on à plus
de 30 millions d'exemplaires
il a été porté à l'écran par victor
fleming deux ans plus tard
le film fait partie des des canons
d'hollywood et et c'est un livre qui est
toujours lui 80 ans après sa sortie
c'est donc dé facto devenu un classique
il est évident que le texte
maintenant est problématique c'est à
dire qu' il ya des passages ouvertement
raciste mais le livre est écrit en 1936
par une jeune femme du sud à l'époque où
la ségrégation raciale était évidemment
très très importante et très brutal aux
états unis et le roman décrit une jeune
fille du sud pendant la guerre de
sécession
donc la vision que nous partageons dans
le livre est celle de cette jeune femme
sudiste qui est donc raciste qui est
dans une société raciste
effectivement même si l'histoire est
avant tout une histoire d'amour
l'histoire des modes de l'émancipation
d'une jeune femme grande fresque
historique où on ne peut pas faire
abstraction de ces passerelles
[Musique]
elle s'est efforcée d'être vraiment la
plus fidèle possible si avant on avait
tendance à écrire les phrases en beau
français un peu ampoulé un peu à la
dix-neuvième faire des phrases un peu
19e siècle elle s'efforçait de respecter
la musicalité du texte et notamment pour
le parler des esclaves de faire autre
chose que de supprimer les airs comme on
le faisait dans les années 30 en mettant
des apostrophes à la place elle s'est
inspirée de maupassant notamment comme
d'un manière dont maupassant faisait
parler
les paysans français et elle a créé un
parler plus chantant en ajoutant des
dessins taxer un peu décalée à la fois
réaliste et à mon sens plus fidèle au
texte original
un coup
si on commence à interdire des films la
question que je me pose c'est quand
commencera tout interdire des livres
il est important de lire des oeuvres
dont on peut s'éloigner
justement pour se forger une opinion
plus plus éclairés en tant qu'éditeur je
pense que il est important de faire
confiance aux lecteurs pour se faire sa
propre opinion
je pense pas qu'on a besoin d'expliquer
de contextualiser tout il est important
que le lecteur puisse ressentir les
passages problématique pour s'en
distancier justement je pense que ça
aide à comprendre mieux le texte une
époque est une problématique qui est
malheureusement toujours d'actualité
aujourd'hui
[Musique]